hi I'm Eric Voss and Star Wars the last
Jedi as densely packed with goodies and
not at all divisive subplots as it was
was nevertheless a product of a ton of
interesting alternate options that never
made it into the final film
unlike other recent Star Wars movies
which all went through a ton of changes
throughout the development process Rian
Johnson's script for the last Jedi was
pretty much a story we saw on screen but
considering his final cut of the movie
was over three hours long it resulted in
around 20 minutes of deleted scenes that
Johnson said could show up in the
blu-ray release let's take a look at
those deleted scenes plus some cool
looking concept art pointing to possible
story directions that were being
considered first let's look at luke's
Island home of atch 2 since this setting
was created for the force awakens in
that final scene there's a ton of
alternate stuff Lucas films artist
designed for it Luke's Jedi Temple was
originally conceived with an odd
metallic architecture including floating
rock domes now this is before they
settled on the more grounded an
elemental look of his home in a final
version some of the art indicated that
Luke and Rey would spend more time on
the water one illustration showed Rey
having crashed landed the Falcon on the
water since she would have been able to
land it on the islands rocky shores with
another picture of Luke and Rey in a
skip as it glides across the way
suggesting at some point they might have
wanted to Falken to sink into the water
and then Luke to rescue rain also at
some point one idea was to have Rey
train with a series of hovering seeker
droids similar to the one Luke trained
with in the first movie thus if Kay
brave he falls into was originally going
to give her some super trippy visions
beyond those mirror reflections one idea
was to have her see the lightsaber duel
between Darth Vader and obi-wan Kenobi
back in the force awakens one of the
ideas for Rey's force vision in that
movie was for her to see Vader fighting
Luke on Cloud City at the end of the
Empire Strikes Back so it sounds like
Rey having to witness these old epic
duels was really being pushed forward by
the creative team same goes for the idea
of SIF ghost some concept art depicts
Luke being haunted by a red SIF ghost
the idea being that if Jedi ghosts have
a bluish tint if ghost will be ready
also at some point the entrance to this
cave was designed to look like the
Emperor's window in Return of the Jedi
the idea being that that window was
reflecting some ancient Jedi sith
symbology that had appeared in other
forms in architecture also for those of
you with the weird rage toward the porgy
during that scene when they were
fiddling with the lightsaber and one
looked
the emitter yes this was based on
concept art where one of those things
cut skewer through the face with it now
you may have remembered promo footage
showing ray running with the lightsaber
drawn which didn't show up in the final
cut this was apparently from one of the
biggest deleted sequences of the movie
during Rey's training she spotted a fire
on the other side of the island and Luke
told her that it was bandits attacking
the caretakers but he plan to stay out
of it because he figured trying to save
them would just make things worse
race brings an action anyway only to
find a big bonfire celebration with the
caretakers in the pours apparently this
is another test by Luke to teach ray
restraint so Rey returned to Luke angry
at him for lying to her snapping that a
legend of Luke Skywalker that you hate
so much I believed in it Jonson ended up
cutting this because Luke tricking Rey
like this just a teacher a lesson made
him come off as even more of a jerk
which the version of the movie would
happen is C and already put off pretty
well moving on and there was also some
scenes to lead it from the canto bite
storyline which is surprising because it
seemed like they left everything
possibly in there but one bit of
dialogue clarified the love triangle
between ray thin and rose rose was gonna
mock Finn for pining for Ray Ray would
deny it claiming he was raised to fight
and then he finally found something to
fight for in his friend ray leaving Rose
to respond jealously whatever then later
when Finn and Rose escaped on the father
years crashing through the casino one of
the deleted scenes included an elaborate
bathhouse set with a bunch of
practically constructed alien puppets
and towels who would freak out and died
out of the way later when these two
bored the supremacy with DJ a lot of
scenes were shot to make this snooping
around sequence a lot more extended
floating the group crawling through a
long laundry chute and then after
stealing the first order officer
uniforms and other scenes showed them
running to a group of stormtroopers one
of whom was played by Tom Hardy he spoke
with a southern accent saying I know who
you are
fn-2187 damn boy I never took you for
officer material the idea was that this
was a stormtrooper who grew up with Finn
and at the troopers it turns out were
completely unaware of Finn's treason
perhaps suggest Senna the first order
would have kept it a secret out of
embarrassment to avoid encouraging
others to defect and another deleted
scene Finn was actually gonna expose
this later on during the fight with
phasma then tells other stormtroopers to
join him calling phasma a coward who
sold out the codes to Starkiller base in
the force awakens but then
the other stormtroopers hesitated phasma
was gonna pull out her blaster and shoot
all of them to keep her secret silent it
was designed as a sort of tribute to old
Sergio Leone style Western shootouts but
they cut it because it just didn't feel
right in that moment that's all the big
stuff we know so far but a question for
you guys what other scenes did make it
in the final cut of the movie that you
think could have been safe for the
deleted scenes personally I could have
done with some more trippy callbacks to
past movies in that cave on Aceh - it
may be a little less of a stuff on can't
abide but I'll throw it over to you guys
let me know your thoughts down below and
tweet me directly at EI boss or probably
new rockstars on twitter at new
rockstars for updates on our videos like
this video and subscribe to new rock
stars for all of our deep dives in the
world of star wars and if you really
like us you can contribute to us on
patreon a big thanks to all of our
donors especially Christina Armstrong
thanks for watching bye
[Music]